so you're a world leader like a powerful
politician or billionaire one could even
say you're part of the global Elite
whatever that means
to get to where you are now you
obviously have to be smarter and much
more capable than the other plebs out
there so you have this era of
superiority around you and you've bought
into the idea that the masses are not
peaceful rational creatures no see wow
society looks relatively peaceful on the
outside we all forget that under the
surface we're all just one meal away
from a revolution see humans are filled
with all these violent sadistic
dangerous animalistic forces that simmer
deep within their unconscious it's in
all of us that's why history is filled
with violence Wars killings torture
chaos and violence are not the exception
to human nature but part of the norm and
all these dangerous forces lurk
underneath modern society as we speak
just waiting to be Unleashed and when
these forces are Unleashed under the
right circumstances the masses turn into
an angry mob armed with pitchforks that
only want one thing your head on a stick
they may not have guns they may not have
the best military equipment but strength
in numbers is a very real thing and
angry mobs have the power to topple even
governments including the elite like you
they're eventually going to want to
pillage you this poses a really really
really big problem if this is what you
believe then it completely goes against
the idea of democracy how can we trust
the masses to make rational decisions if
humans are irrational at their core if
it is true that humans are driven by
these dangerous animalistic forces then
these clubs can't be trusted we can't
have democracy we need to systematically
rethink democracy what we need is a
group of only the smartest most capable
people on Earth the global Elite like
you to get together to manage this
bewildered herd we gotta protect the
masses from themselves we gotta round
them up disarm them make them
comfortable make life easy ask some
control measures while keeping them
distracted all in an effort to make them
docile enough so that these powerful
unconscious forces never have a chance
of erupting the problem is changing
democracy as we know it is a really big
change clubs don't like really big
changes on top of that democracy has
such a Rosy sound to the plebs they
think it's a source of all good so when
you the elites are saying that we need
changed democracy they're going to be
suspicious the plebs aren't going to be
receptive to it they haven't been primed
however there is a shortcut to this rule
of humans not wanting big change a
crisis
there's a reason why Winston Churchill
once said never let a good crisis go to
waste
[Applause]
it's because when there's a crisis when
the masses are suffering they beg for a
saver they beg for a solution and
they'll listen to just about anyone who
has the Gus to stand on a Podium and
point out who the evil bad guy is while
offering a convenient solution in this
case it would be restructuring democracy
as we know it this is what you need the
perfect crisis to give the world a
little recess luckily the perfect crisis
just happened two years ago people were
thrown into poverty the masses suddenly
became open to insane amounts of
surveillance and control it destroyed
the global economy so you the elite
slipped the perfect solution into the
Public's Consciousness a little
something called the Great reset a grand
restructuring of society as we know it
reshaping the way the masses live spend
do business all in an effort to keep the
dangerous animalistic forces of the
masses from ever getting out of hand and
this plan is led by a little-known
organization called the world economic
Forum or wef the wef is a unique beast
on the outside the Wes sounds so
innocent it's a forum about world
economics nothing more take a look on
their website and you'll see that oh
they talk about rising sea levels peace
security development 11 world leader
leader in the inside it is something far
far more Sinister the wef is a group of
the most powerful people on the planet
CEOs billionaires world leaders funded
by 1 000 of some of the world's biggest
corporations they systematically
influence politicians and infiltrate
positions of power in countries all over
the world all in an effort to shape the
world into their vision of what it
should look like which sounds a lot like
a de facto World Government but it's not
a government it's not a business no one
voted them into office and yet here they
are using their publishings to push the
world towards their plan for a great
reset and it's all spearheaded by one
man Klaus Schwab and almost everything
is already falling into place
stay dangerous and this is the great
research
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to be successful and Rich
like these guys you gotta put the best
fuel possible in your body that's why I
take my diet a lot more seriously these
days but it wasn't always like this
growing up I was obsessed with chocolate
and fruity cereal until I found out that
these cereals are absolutely horrible
for you that's why I was so excited when
I found out about magic spoon magic
spoon is healthy cereal that tastes way
too good to be true it is the only
cereal I eat these days and it really
gives you that childhood Nostalgia with
zero grams of sugar only four to five
net grams of carbs per serving and 13 to
14 grams of protein per serving we've
got cocoa which is my favorite
ah
super chocolatey and tastes really
unhealthy just the way I like it but it
actually is healthy and to get you guys
started magic spoon is giving you guys
five dollars offer your own variety box
by going to magicspoon.com and using the
code jtran with the link below us Canada
and the UK so pause the video and go to
magicspoon.com with the link below
thanks to Magic spoon for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
step one in the great reset we can't
keep the plebs in line if we don't know
what they're doing every second of every
day we need to see everything we need to
know everything once we have that Intel
then we can start rewarding or punishing
them to keep them in line that's why
we're working on the perfect solution
the digital ID instead of carrying your
normal ID or passport you will soon have
a digital ID that you will use for every
aspect of life to access health care and
other vital services to check into
hotels and book international flights
you will use your digital ID to handle
your taxes everything will be connected
to your digital ID all for your safety
and convenience of course I mean it only
makes sense right most of us have one
email we use for our entire online Lives
why not have the equivalent of that for
our physical lives as Klaus Schwab said
quote in the near future similar
monitoring systems will also be applied
to the movement and tracking of people
end quote from where you go to shop to
what you eat to the trips you take they
will track your habits and behavior
every second of the day now we know what
you're thinking this sounds way too
far-fetched that could never happen oh
but it has already all you have to do is
look to our neighbors in the East let's
say China China China China ah yes China
in China everything you do or purchase
is tied to your identity your flights
your train rides Etc it's all overseen
by the gracious Chinese Communist party
which gives them some unique methods of
social control and guess who is a big
fan of China Klaus Schwab of course
Schwab thinks China is doing a fantastic
job and that we should model our Western
world based on Chinese values here's him
introducing the great Xi Jinping at the
Davos agenda of 2022.
China has made significant economic and
social achievements under your
leadership we now welcome his Excellency
shishimping president of the People's
Republic of China
but we can't stop at just knowing what
our plebs are doing no we gotta continue
following in China's footsteps see once
you have the data on what your subjects
are doing now we need to give them some
way of knowing if they're being obedient
enough or not kind of like a scoreboard
for a video game the plebs need some
kind of feedback loop to see how they're
doing which brings us to step two of the
great reset
foreign
also known as the social credit score
the system is simple it's like training
a dog but for the masses simply set up
the rules for your servants track their
actions if their actions are in line
with the rules increase their score if
not decrease their score but when we
talk about rules we're not talking about
basic rules like do not steal or do not
murder the masses already understand and
respect those rules we're talking about
Behavior
vote your score will drop if you
criticize the government on Tick Tock
your score will drop if you live too
lavishly your score will drop an
alternative or maybe the first version
of the social credit score is the
so-called carbon footprint tracker
at billion consumers we're developing
through technology and ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform so
individual carbon footprint tracker stay
tuned we don't have it operational yet
but this is something that we're working
on
but here's the thing a scoreboard is
useless if there aren't any rewards or
Consequences for their actions so after
we have the score we need to create the
carrot and the stick
[Music]
step 3 now it's time to add some rewards
and punishments for your pleb's actions
maybe they're eating too much meat you
want to block their access to certain
restaurants or products after all meat
is bad for the environment right if you
see them buying too many books that are
critical of the government you might
want to block their Audible and Kindle
accounts maybe a big protest is breaking
out in a certain area and your plebs are
trying to travel to it to participate
simply lock them out of ride sharing
apps and block them from buying tickets
for flights or trains like what China
did to people who were traveling to
protest Banks freezing their accounts in
this specific case the Chinese
government relied on their citizens
covet contact tracing during covid
citizens had to sign up for an app that
would track their covid status and
whether or not they had been in contact
with anyone who tested positive if your
profile was green you have not been
exposed to anyone with covid and you
could travel and work but if your code
was yellow or red you have to say
goodbye to your ability to shop use
public transport or go to work when the
protests broke out they changed
everyone's covet status to Red that way
none of them would be able to travel or
gather to protest handy right but China
takes it even further than just using
this for extreme cases like protesting
every year China bans millions of people
from buying plane tickets because their
social credit score is too low
[Music]
even their children aren't allowed into
good schools anymore just because their
parents did something the government
sees as bad behavior
think about how powerful that social
pressure is oh your daughter didn't get
into a good school she must be stupid or
you must be a really bad person
in China if you don't play by the
government's rules they will turn you
and your family into social outcasts
and this dystopian future isn't even as
far away as most of us imagine
it looks like Italy is rolling out
Europe's first social credit system this
year good citizens will get rewarded for
doing things like separating their trash
from recycling using public transport
instead of their own car conserving
energy in their home obedience stuff
like that this new social credit program
only includes rewards for now no
punishments yet and if it rolls out more
cities are sure to follow
but there's one more critical step to
gaining full control over Society money
thank you
step 4 control the money
today many of us already pay by swiping
our credit card or phones over some
electronic device so most of our
transactions are already being tracked
but there is still a lot of cash flowing
around in this world as the world
economic Forum we don't like that at all
why because cash is offline we can't see
what they're buying if it's in cash
plebs could withdraw 100 from their bank
account and buy a Banned Book on the
black market for crying out loud or they
could blow all that money in a
gentleman's club this is a big No-No so
another goal of the wef and Klaus Schwab
is to introduce a single digital
currency to be used all over the world
kinda like Bitcoin but with a Twist
unlike Bitcoin which is completely
decentralized their digital currency
would be fully centralized they call it
Central Bank digital currency or cbdc
and they're working on it as we speak oh
I'm quite done glad to hear what you're
saying uh
digital currency not coin I am also
believer that will come in five years
yes what I try to say is obviously you
know we still have those huge Legacy
environment they need to migrate as well
so we will not yet see all the benefits
coming through but it will come and will
be much more efficient also probably
much more secure lowering transaction
costs on the retail side are much more
skeptical certainly call it for the you
know established economies this digital
currency would still live on the
blockchain so every single transaction
is on there forever and can't be altered
but any sense of anonymity would go
straight out of the window every
transaction throughout the entire
economy could be tracked and analyzed
like never before and the entire
currency would be managed by a central
Authority and it would still allow them
to do neat things like print money on
command and if they spend money on
things that are against our agenda we
could freeze their bank account we
already saw a glimpse of that during the
truckers protest in Canada the truckers
went against the system they voiced
their opinions and the government froze
their bank accounts
so we already know world leaders want to
do this a central bank digital currency
would just make it a lot more efficient
digital cash could be programmed to
ensure it is only spent on Essentials or
Goods which an employer or government
deems to be sensible holy [ __ ] I'm gonna
take it one step further future all
right but it doesn't stop there on top
of controlling their money plebs still
have one source of economic power that
we need to strip away from them property
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Schwab and the world economic Forum
predict that by 2030 you will own
nothing and you will be happy plebs
won't own a car they won't own a house
they won't even own your cooking
equipment don't believe us here's an
actual quote from an article the world
economic Forum wrote in Forbes titled
welcome to 2030. I own nothing have no
privacy and life has never been better
quote welcome to the year 2030. Welcome
To My City or should I say our city I
don't own anything I don't own a car I
don't own a house I don't own any
appliances or any clothes it might seem
odd to you but it makes perfect sense
for us in this city everything you
considered a product has now become a
service in our city we don't pay any
rent because someone else is using our
free space whenever we don't need it my
living room is used for business
meetings when I am not there shopping I
can't really remember what that is
once in a while I get annoyed about the
fact that I have no real privacy nowhere
I can go and not be registered I know
that somewhere everything I do think and
dream of is recorded I just hope that
nobody will use it against me they
literally wrote this in the article we
had to do a double take to make sure
that this is in fact the world economic
forum's official Forbes account all in
all it is a good life end quote ah yes
life will be good when Mega corporations
own literally everything no one has any
private property and your entire life
will be at the mercy of those who do own
the property kinda like feudalism but
you'll be safe you won't have to worry
about anything anymore everything will
be for your convenience
and if the convenience argument doesn't
convince the plebs he'll trip them with
climate change and how they're ruining
the planet quote all in all it is a good
life much better than the path we were
on where it became so clear that we
could not continue with the same model
of growth we had all these terrible
things happening lifestyle diseases
climate change the refugee crisis
environmental degradation completely
congested cities water pollution air
pollution social unrest and unemployment
we lost way too many people before we
realized that we could do things
differently end quote
but behind closed doors you and I know
that it's all about power and control so
now that we know our end game of where
we need the world to end up how are we
gonna get there how are we actually
gonna get the world to transform into
our vision it's going to take a lot of
new laws a lot of new policies and laws
and policies are changed by politicians
that means we got to get influence and
infiltrate the world's politicians we
gotta turn as many of them as possible
into our marionettes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
one way the wef influences politicians
and people in positions of power to
think their way is through their annual
meeting in Davos this is the Wes fancy
annual event where the rich and Powerful
literally gather to discuss and
strategize where to take the world next
artificial intelligence climate change
cyber security the metaverse and other
buzzwords like that are all discussed at
Davos so all participants can feel
special and important while at the same
time the wef slides in things they want
to push like the great reset agenda but
what if there was a much more effective
way of spreading the wef's goals What If
instead of waiting until Davos to try to
convince politicians to agree with you
once a year what if you could avoid all
of this in the first place what if
politicians from around the world were
already bought into the wef's philosophy
from the start that's exactly what Klaus
Schwab had in mind when he founded the
Forum of young global leaders in 2004 a
sort of internship program to train the
leaders of tomorrow according to the
website the goal is to mold young people
into strong leaders who will quote shape
a more inclusive and sustainable future
end quote in other words
wef and Klaus Schwab are training young
power-hungry wannabe leaders in their
ideology and political ideas they are
telling them exactly what kind of future
they will be fighting for and they have
been silently infiltrating governments
around the world for decades
when I mention now names like Mrs Merkel
even Vladimir Putin and so on say all
have been young global leaders of the
world economic form what we are very
proud of now is the Young Generation
like prime minister Trudeau
president of
Argentina and so on certainly penetrates
the cabinets so yesterday I was at a
reception for primitive
and I would know that half of this
cabinet or even more of a half of this
cabinet are for our actually young Nobel
leaders of the world
but no one knows exactly what they are
teaching those leaders of the future no
one knows what they're being trained for
their political agenda or how much power
they will eventually have over certain
countries and when people start asking
questions strange things happen thank
you Mr Speaker and I listen to my
colleague speech I had a constituent
that wanted me to ask a question about
outside interference to our democracy
Klaus Schwab is the head of the world
economic forum and he bragged how his
subversive WWEF World economic Forum has
quoted infiltrated governments around
the world he said that his organization
had penetrated more than half of
Canada's cabinet and I was wondering in
the interest of transparency could the
member please name which cabinet
ministers are on board with the wef's
agenda my concern is the Deputy order
order I I know he was I know that the
member was in a really good good
question there but the the audio is
really really bad and the video is
really really bad as well
um and I and I and I apologize I don't
know if if the member okay uh let's
let's uh let's try again the honor of
the
The Honorable member for Tim's James Bay
voting open disinformation that's not
debate we have to call up this
information uh we're gonna get into
debate again
strange I didn't have any trouble
hearing the question and apparently the
other Member of Parliament heard well
enough to dismiss it as disinformation
and voila there you have it the great
reset and how the wef plans to get there
but it's important to note that although
yes the great reset is very suspect it
still is just a plan at the end of the
day a goal that they're hoping to make
into reality
sure they have a lot of money influence
and powerful people that believe in it
but the good news is that all of this is
still your choice at the end of the day
you get to choose whether or not you put
up with more surveillance in exchange
for convenience and security you get to
choose whether or not you own any
possessions so choose and Choose Wisely
it seems like the world economic forum
and its leader Klaus Schwab are working
tirelessly on getting more and more
control over society and if we're not
careful we may end up as prisoners in an
evil system getting brainwashed 24 hours
a day but the wef isn't the first
organization that wants full control
over people to turn them into mindless
puppets the beginning in the 1950s the
CIA ran a very special program called MK
Ultra
and it was one of the darkest projects
the CIA ever called into life the
scientists behind MK Ultra would test
all sorts of drugs and torture
techniques on as many people as they
could
with the goal of finding the perfect
combination of chemicals and
psychological or physical abuse to
create a completely controllable puppet
they wanted the ability to create a
Manchurian Candidate a programmed killer
who would kill on command without any
remorse and forget about it a moment
later
but talking about all the details of MK
Ultra the torture and so forth would
definitely get demonetized if we were to
post it publicly that's why we've
released a private documentary into
every dark evil secret MK Ultra holds
available only to members of this
Channel and so far members have been
loving the documentary all you have to
do to get access to this video on MK
Ultra is to click the join button below
once you're a member of our Channel you
will also have access to all the other
private documentaries like our latest
one on the connection between Victoria's
Secret and everyone's favorite island
owner Jeffrey jepstein and you get all
of this knowledge that the world will
never teach you for just five dollars a
month and there's a refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships so if
you join and you don't think it's worth
it email us within your first month of
joining and we will personally refund
you for your first month after your
first month there is no refund so scroll
down and hit that join button now
I personally usually don't like videos
like this because they usually never
provide a clear motive as to why someone
will want to do this if they're in a
position of power so I really want to
emphasize that in this video so it makes
more sense but yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you're new here this is
one of the biggest channels on YouTube
for documentaries on money power war and
crimes you can learn how the world
really works instead of becoming a
victim to it so if you like the
philosophy if you want to be more
dangerous click that subscribe button
below if you follow me on Instagram
jaketran but that is going to wrap it up
thanks for being part of the watch to
the end Club stay dangerous out there
and I will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign